le gars amis qui nous a rendu un hommage
noces et silvan à tpm père gardez un des
membres du jury c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi c'est pas du tout ce qui
était prévu parce c'était pas le numéro
que de bien faire
[Musique]
clessé
pensez pas une surprise mais j'ai rien
compris c'était la même blague répéter
répéter répéter tu prends beaucoup de
petits rites enfin gros n'importe où
ouais c'est un peu comme touche pas à
mon poste
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai eu alors j'ai envoyé un petit
message aux sugar sammy aujourd'hui on
sent pas jeune et j'espère qu'on fait
sympa non non mais votent oui tout va
trés c'est bravo tout y est vue par sms
et jeudi j'espère qu'on va se croiser
bientôt mes potes je vous jure que c'est
vrai ou pas oui il m'a dit cyril aux
plaisirs bon grand n'importe quoi ce
soit oui on va devoir bien caché il a
dit qu'elle était et j'espère qu'il va
vite au canada voyez pas avec cette
balle j'ai peut-être gratter habillée
très bien votre tweet et oissel durable
et ouais c'est franchement une membrane
tout le monde si on n'accepte pas l'aval
des autres doit arrêter un
en plus c'était pas méchant du tout est
hyper sympa par sms envoyé des trucs
soulisse matin et boudy il vous souhaite
un bon n'importe quoi ce soir je garde
ça lui qui doit peut-être nous regarde
et on lui fait un gros bisou voilà alors
il ya eu ça alors c'est vrai qu'ils
iront là on en a parlé mais surtout hier
il ya karine le marchand qui a déclenché
son golden buzzer son golden buzzer qui
lui permit de quitter l'émission et ne
plus jamais revenir
malheureusement ce n'est pas ça